what are they emergence mean I mean
phase transitions emerge from the forces
that act between particles it's true
that there are features of phase
transitions which don't depend on the
details of those forces it's also true
that they're facts about triangles that
don't depend on the details of how the
triangles are made but you if in order
to answer the question whether or not
those features apply in any particular
physical system you have to understand
how those features of phase transitions
emerge use the word in the particular
microscopic system you're talking about
and you know not all systems have the
same critical exponents the whole theory
doesn't always work it works when there
is a logical necessity for it to work
based on more fundamental principles I
don't know of any case where we have
generalizations at least within physics
I don't know that much about biology but
within physics I don't know any case
will we have general principles that we
can't see emerging from a lower level
and we can identify the fundamental
level from which they thought which from
which they are entailed I don't I mean
that's like disagree very strongly with
what you said about phase transitions
okay can I just say I one of the
interests here is now there's a there's
a sort of physical story about emergence
so we could struggle with but it seems
to me that the reason we're interested
in the topic is is and this is different
people maybe but is partly because
there's this naturalism non naturalism
distinction the question is what's going
to fit in our naturalism story are we
going to eliminate in
strong sense and and that's what this
morning was struggling with what are we
going to eliminate and what are our
principles for eliminating them my sense
is that we don't want to be too hasty at
what we eliminate and that's and if
that's going to allow the religious
fundamentalists to say AHA these these
guys don't really have it all together
yet that's fine with me because I want
to know what's the case not not about
what they will take and run with as an
evolutionary biologist I have been
through my whole career battling against
these people I get letters probably
every two or three days from somebody
that you know tells me I'm about to go
to hell or whatever because of my
beliefs and because I'm messing up all
these young minds sending them to the
devil I don't worry about that I want to
know how it works and if they take what
I'm doing is sort of helping them along
their game I'm not too worried so long
as I figure out what I'm talking about
so I I want to be this is I think the
political side of this question the
dinosaur pimping that I think what we
want to know is what is the case well
but I mean it's like Max and I thinks
that Steve's argument it's not a
knock-down are you even though the
history of physics shows only a one way
progression that things get entailed but
lower levels but the little that the
higher levels don't entail the lower
levels okay again bottom-up top-down
game yeah is there a case in which you
can show that a higher level emergence
Property cannot be consonant with
something well what I don't believe that
there is such a thing I mean I mean I
could make up things like if there was
an innate tendency of life to improve as
used to be thought before Darwin people
believed in evolution but they thought
it was because life it's a law of life
that life type tries to improve and if
that were true I would say well you know
that just means that the separate
biological laws they are not and they
are not entailed by physical laws we
live in a world governed by different
bodies of law and we just have to live
with that but I mean it was a great
right through to realize that that's not
true that in fact although you don't put
it in terms of elementary particles the
kind of thing that allows life to get
better is the kind of thing that can be
entailed by the deeper level of
elementary particles
you